in this video we'll finally see how we
can train a conditional random field and
so will first discuss the last function
that we'll use to train and learn our
conditional random field so in the
previous videos we've defined what we
meant by a linear chain conditional
random field so that's the specific
conditional random field we'll consider
so P of Y given X square Y is a sequence
of label and X is sequence of inputs is
going to be the exponential of a sum of
unary potential log factors and pairwise
log factors divided by normalization
constant that we have to compute with
some dynamic programming using the
forward backward algorithm and so thus
far in the previous videos I always
assumed that our conditional random
field was already trained and I've
talked about how we can perform
inference compute the partition function
perform classification and so on
so now we'll finally look at how we can
train a conditional random field on some
available data so again we'll use
empirical risk minimization as our
guiding principle for deriving and
learning algorithm that is we are going
to choose a loss function and to train a
conditional random field on training the
training set that is a set of pairs of
input sequences and target sequences or
label sequences will minimize the
average of the sum of the loss function
where we compare to what extent our
model fits well with the target sequence
information we have so we'll optimize
this average loss along so plus the way
the regularizer to control to what
extent we won our model to fit well the
data and to be able to control for
overfitting so again we're casting
learning as optimization like we've done
in the regular neural network and though
ideally we'd like to optimize the
classification error so in this case
perhaps would like to optimize the sum
of per label classification there this
error again is non smooth so we have to
use what we use
we call a surrogate loss or an
alternative loss that sort of looks like
what we want to optimize but that is
better behaved and specifically in this
case is going to be differentiable so we
can perform gradient descent training
and again we'll use stochastic gradient
descent that is the way where training
is going to proceed is that we'll first
initialize the parameters of our model
for a certain number of iterations will
cycle through our pairs of input
sequences and target sequences we'll
compute the update direction which is
going to be minus the gradient of the
loss for my current pair of input and
target sequences - also the gradient of
the regularizer and then I'll take a
small step
so alpha times the update direction to
change my vector from is my set of
parameters and so again I have to
specify a loss function a specified
procedure for computing the gradient
with respect to the loss function I also
have to specify the regularizer and its
gradient as well as the initialization
method so these two parts are not really
going to change so we're not really
gonna guess discussed them will focus on
choosing a loss function and also
specifying how we compute the parameter
gradient and in this particular video
we'll look at the loss function would
optimize so again because a conditional
random field estimates the conditional
probability of the target given the
input what is an actual thing to do is
to maximize the probability assigned to
the true target the sequence given some
input sequence as extracted from our
training set and as we've seen in the
case of a regular neural network instead
of maximizing probabilities we can
minimize the negative log of the
probability which is more better behaved
and yield simpler math and so to firm it
as a minimization problem we minimize
the negative log likelihood so our last
function with the minus the log of the
probability of the true target so
normally this would be the true target
given the
input sequence so this is really the
same that we've done in a regular neural
network where we have an input vector
and we're trying to classify it to do a
set of C classes the only difference is
that now this is a sequence and this is
also a sequence one sort of subtle
difference also is that while in
non-sequential classification if you
have ten classes we might actually
explicitly compute the full conditional
distribution P of Y given X by iterating
over all classes and so obtaining the
full vector of probability now with a
sequence we can do this because the
number of sequences is exponential so
really when we're computing this we'll
use forward backward to get our alpha or
beta table and to compute the partition
function and we'll use then explicitly
the partition function into the
expression for P of Y given X and then
we'll take minus the log of that so we
won't actually compute we don't have the
full distribution over all sequences
that just because that's too big of an
object it's something that's there's an
exponential of all sequences that I
would be an exponential number of
probabilities so that's the last
function we'll use for training a
conditional random field